people are coming in illegally and they
are breaking a law listen whether you
like it or not that's what's happening
and then the sheriff's in Texas or the
border patrol I don't know who these
people are I don't know who it is Walker
Texas Ranger I don't know but they're
they're Rangers these are real live
Texas law enforcement and they're on
Horseback and they're doing what they do
it doesn't look great I think they're
lassoing the migrant I don't think
they're whipping they're doing a lasso
which is not easy that is a difficult
thing to do they're on Horseback now
remember the migrants are not just
waiting to be lassoed they're running
they're running around and you are on
Horseback with the lasso and it's got to
be big because M much like a cartoon you
are lassoing lots of people